اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير متابعينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا
المساء
بحجه تهديد الامن القومي البيت الابيض
يمهل الوكالات الفيدراليه 30 يوما لحذف
تطبيق تيك توك
تعترض فما الخطر الذي يشكله تيك توك على
امريكا
في الملف الثاني بين التزاماته الدوليه
واسعيه لتهدئه من جهه وبين وزرائه
المتطرفين من جهه اخرى نتنياهو في مازق
صنعه بيده فكيف سيخرج رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي من ورطته
وفي الملف الثالث موسكو تتحدث او تحدد
شرطها الاساسي لاستئناف محادثات نيو ستارت
النوويه اوقفوا دعم اوكرانيا وسمعوا
لمطالب امن القومي فهل تساوي واشنطن على
دعم كياف
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل المخاوف الغربيه من
تطبيق التواصل الاجتماعي المملوك للصين
تيك توك تتزايد يوما بعد يوم وسط تراشق في
تصريحات والاتهامات بين واشنطن
وفي اخر التطورات الصين اعلنت رفضها التام
للقرار الامريكي الاخير بشان حظر تطبيق
تيك توك الذي يخضع لتدقيق متزايد في
واشنطن وقالت الخارجيه الصينيه ان
الولايات المتحده تقمع الشركات الاجنبيه
وتتجاوز مفهوم الامن القومي موقف رافض اتى
بعد ان منح البيت الابيض جميع الوكالات
الفيدراليه 30 يوما لازاله تطبيق تيك توك
من جميع الاجهزه الحكوميه وبالفعل وضعت
بعض الوكالات ومن بينها وزارات الدفاع
والامن الداخلي والخارجيه بعض القيود على
تيك توك تطبيق تيك توك مشاهدينا يتمتع
بشعبيه كبيره في امريكا والعالم وهو تطبيق
يختلف عن النسخه المستخدمه في الصين كليا
الفرنسيه قالت ان الاختلافات بين النسختين
الصينيه والدوليه من منصه تيك توك تثير
التساؤل حول وجود
نيه لتحويل الاطفال الى اغبياء عن طريق
هذه القوات الناعمه دراسات في الصين
وامريكا كذلك ساعات لاكتشاف المهنه مثلا
التي يريدها الشباب من مستخدمي تيك توك
فكان الجواب في امريكا شخصيه مؤثره على
وسائل التواصل بينما كانت الاجابه في
الصين رائد فضاء
الغرب منذ اشهر
مخاوف امنيه مخاوف متزايده من امكانيه
وصول الصين لبيانات المستخدمين عبر
التطبيق
ديسمبر الماضي الكونجرس اقر قانونا ينص
على عدم استخدام تيك توك في الاجهزه
الحكوميه
الحكومه الكنديه حضرت التطبيق على كل
هواتفها واجهزتها مشيره الى مخاوفه على
صعيد حمايه البيانات
المفوضيه الاوروبيه حضرت الاسبوع الماضي
التطبيق على اجهزتها
شعبيه كبيره لا يزال تيك توك المملوك
لشركه
يحظى بشعبيه كبيره ويستخدمه ثلث المراهقين
في امريكا
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
ايهاب عباس المحلل السياسي ومن دبي
تشوتشوانا الصحفي في مجموعه الصين للاعلام
اهلا بكم ماذا في الكريمين واسمح لي ان
ابدا من واشنطن معك استاذ ايهاب استاذ
ايهاب واشنطن تعتبر بان منصه تيك توك تهدد
امنها القومي هل تعتقد فعلا بان مخاوف
واشنطن هي مخاوف مشروعه
وبكل المشاهدين اللي نضع مبدا رئيسيا قبل
ان نتحدث في هذا الموضوع وهو ان كل
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي تقوم بجمع
البيانات والمعلومات سواء كانت هذه
الوسائل مملوكه لدول كالصين مثلا يقال انه
مبروك شركه
انه مملوك للحكومه الصينيه او حتى لم يكن
المملوكا للحكومه الصينيه والشركات الاخرى
مثل جوجل وفيسبوك
ويوتيوب
واتساب كل هذه الوسائل تجمع بيانات ضخمه
وكثيره الغرض الرئيس من هذه البيانات هو
ان يتم المتاجره ببيانات العملاء وبيعها
للشركات تقوم تقدم الدعايه الى اخره لصنع
المال ليه يعني الحصول على اموال ومكاسب
كبيره جدا هناك من يستخدم هذه الوسائل
لايضا التجسس وجمع البيانات المتعلقه
بالافراد
وقدراتهم وتحركاتهم والاماكن المهمه التي
يعملون فيها الى اخره هل هذا معني بالصين
فقط لا اعتقد الجميع يجمع معلومات عن
الجميع الصين تجمع عن امريكا امريكا تجمع
عن الصين روسيا تجمع عن الاثنين اوروبا
تجمع الجميع ايضا فبالتالي هذا هو المبدا
الرئيسي طيب هل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اليوم
بمثل هذا القرار هل هو قرار صحيح هو قرار
صحيح ومتاخر ولكن لن يمنع اي شيء هناك
اكثر من 115 او 120 مليون تقريبا مستخدم
لتيك توك داخل الولايات المتحده تستطيع
الصين ان تتعقبهم جميعا وتعلم تحركاتهم
حتى لو كانوا موظفين فيدراليين منعت
الحكومه الفيدراليه هذه الاماكن من ان
يكون على اجهزتها تيك توك لكن هؤلاء على
المستوى الشخصي هم موظفون لديهم هواتفهم
النقاله الشخصيه ولديهم عليها تيك توك
تستطيع الصين اذا ما ارادت اختراق
البيانات وجمعه تستطيع فعل ذلك بسهوله
كبيره نعم السيد
هذه المنصه قادره على تهديد امها القومي
وظيفه يقول بان قرارات واشنطن صحيحه
ومتاخره تعليقك
الصراحه اعتقد ان سبب اتخاذ هذا القرار
عجيب شويه من المعروف ان الولايات المتحده
هي اقوى دول في كل انها العالم ولديها
كثيرا من الكويت العسكريه خارج البلاد
ولكنها الان تقول انها تخاف من تطبيق
اجتماعيه يهبه الشباب الامريكيون اعتقد ان
ذلك هودجا للولايات المتحده فقط
نعرف انها ليست ثمره الاولى التي تقدر مثل
هذه القرارات فقالت الحكومات الامريكيه ان
اتخاذ القرار بسببه حمايه الامن القومي
ولكن هل لديها اي دليل واضح او ثابت لذلك
اعتقد اسباب برج حقيقيه هو خوف الولايات
المتحده الشديده من تقاطميه والتكنولوجيه
الصيني من المعروف ان الصين نقاط التطور
مستمرا في مجالات الاقتصاديه والالمنيه
والتكنولوجيا وغيرها من المجالات الاخرى
واعلى رغمي بان الص ين يعني قد ابدت وديه
ان انها تعتبر الولايات المتحده شريكا
اقتصاديا تجاريا مهم جدا بالنسبه لها ولكن
للاسف شديد تعتبر الولايات المتحده الصين
منافسا استراتيجيا يعني حتى من
اقوى تحدي لها في ساحه سياسيه فهكذا
حضرتك تؤكد بانه من ابرز الاسباب التي ادت
الى هكذا قرار هو التطور التكنولوجي
الصيني الذي تهابه واشنطن اسمح لي ان انقل
هذه النقطه للسيد ايهاب سيد ايهاب هل
تعتقد بان واشنطن لم تقدم سبب الحقيقي
وسبب الحقيقي وربما تتفق مع ضيفه الذي
يقول بان مخاوف وعشط حقيقيه هي من التوسع
والتطور المحدود لتكنولوجيا الصينيه
يعني اتفق بجزء بسيط جدا لكن في المجمل هو
بالفعل يشكل خطر على الامن القومي
الامريكي الجزء الذي اتفق فيه هو انه يعني
الصين صحيح تتقدم تكنولوجيا وهذه
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه تنعكس على الاقتصاد
الصيني والقدرات العسكريه الصينيه وقدرات
التجاريه الصينيه
ولكن ليس بالمقدار الذي يرهب الولايات
المتحده ويخيفها اتحدث عن التكنولوجيا
نفسها ليس الان ربما في المستقبل من
الممكن لماذا اقول ذلك لان الصين ليست
لديها ما يسمى بالنهاوي يعني القدره على
انشاء التكنولوجيا هي الصين دائما تقوم
بطبع التكنولوجيا التي ينتجها الاخرون في
هذه المرحله لا اعتقد وهذا امر خطير ايضا
يعني تعلمين حضرتك هناك الاف القضايا
مرفوعه على شركات صينيه بسبب حقوق الملكيه
وحقوق البراءات الاختراع المتعلقه
بالتكنولوجيا الى اخره عندما تتحول
لقادر على انتاج التكنولوجيا التكنولوجيا
يعني منذ البدايه دون الاستعانه باي قدرات
تكنولوجيه غربيه اعتقد عندها ستكون بالفعل
مجابهه بشكل كبير للغرب والولايات المتحده
وربما منافس خطير جدا
في موضوع اخر كنت منذ قليل تحدثت وطرحت
سؤال بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا
تملك دلائل على انه هذه
او هذه المنصه هي منصه قادره ان تهدد
الامن القومي الامريكي ولكن هناك دراسات
قامت بها واشنطن تؤكد في صبر ارى بان
الاطفال والشباب المراهقين لما سئلوا عن
الوظيفه التي يريدون من اتهانها قالوا
مؤثر على مواقع التواصل بينما في الصين
رائد فضاء المنصتين مختلفتان بين الغرب
وما تملكه الصين في الداخل اليست هذه او
التي تمثل هذه الشكوك حقيقيه
كل التقدير والاحترام طبعا هل تسمح الصين
للولايات المتحده او شركات خاصه حتى في
الولايات المتحده ان تقوم بانشاء شبكات 5
جي داخل الصين هل ستسمح الصين بذلك هذا
امر يتعلق بالامن القومي لانه يدخل في
اطار البنيه التحتيه
التي تجمع من خلالها الشركات بيانات
ومعلومات مهمه جدا عن المستخدمين فاذا ما
سمحت الصين بهذا لشركات الامريكيه عندها
من الممكن ان نقول ان في المقابل عدم سماح
الولايات المتحده يعد طبعا شيئا خطا لكن
هل تسمح يعني سؤالي لحضرتك هل تسمح الصين
لشركه امريكيه تستثمر في مجال البنيه
التحتيه داخل الصين
نعم كلامك صحيح يا استاذ ولكن كما نعرف ان
نسرين قد حزام وطريق وذلك لاجل تحسين بنيه
التحتيه واعتقد بما فيها
الظروف ظروف المواصلات او ظروف الاتصالات
هي شركه هي من منتجات صينيه الذات
والتكنولوجيا العليه العليه فاعتقد ان هذا
دول اخرى فاعتقد ان كثيرا من الدول حتى في
اوروبيه يعني قد استخدمت هذه تكنولوجيا
ايضا
فلماذا فقط الولايات المتحده تخاف من ذلك
ولكنك كذلك سيد شو تصر على طرح نقطه اخرى
حضرتك تفصل بين المؤسسات الحكوميه
والمؤسسات الغير حكوميه وهنا يطرح السؤال
بالنظر الى طبيعه الحكم داخل الصين هل
يمكن الحديث بطريقه
دقيقه على مؤسسات غير حكوميه لا تتبع او
لا على الاقل تتحكم فيها او ليست للحكومه
الصينيه ايه سلطه عليها
اعتقد الشركه شركه هو شركه هي من مؤسسه
غيره حكوميه ابدا لان
في الحقيقه
مؤسس للشركه ومؤسسه مؤسسات خير من
المنصورين الحكوميين
وليس لديها حصه
الحكومه الصينيه حصه في شركه فاعتقد ان
هذا من شركات غير الحكوميه ليس مصر
ابعد من الحكومه الصينيه تمتلك حصه ام لا
اريد سماع تعليقك استاذ ايهاب هل يمكن
الفصل بين مؤسسات حكوميه وغير حكوميه
يعني اذا تحدثنا عن داخل الولايات المتحده
يمكن الفصل
بشكل تام نعم انا يعني اعطي فقط الديباجه
للاستاذ شو يعني
وللمشاهد لكن في الصين بكل تاكيد لا طبعا
لا لا طبعا السبب في ذلك هو قدرات الحزب
الشيوعي الحاكم في الصين على السيطره على
اي شيء وكل شيء في لحظه اذا ما اراد ان
يتاكد من خطوره او عدم خطوره هذا الشيء
ونتذكر ما حدث مع احد رجال الاعمال اصحاب
منصات البيع الشهيره على على الانترنت
عندما اختفى لفتره وثارت الاقاويل حوله
فيما يتعلق بعلاقته بالحكومه الصينيه
وايضا ما يتعلق بشركه هواوي ولو تتذكري
حضرتك استاذه ريم اعتقد منذ ثلاثه اعوام
او ما يقرب الحكومه الكنديه اوقفت رئيسه
الشركه في كندا
والولايات المتحده حاولت ان تمنع وربما
منعت بشكل كبير جدا توغل هذه الشركه في
اوروبا بعد ما تاكدت لها تفاصيل بانها
مقربه من الحكومه الصينيه كانت ستقوم
بانشاء شبكات 5 جي داخل اوروبا ربما انشقت
بعضها لكن الاوروبيين علامه اعلمه اليوم
نادمون على هذا القرار سيبقى موضوعا
للمتابعه
جزيل الشكر من واشنطن ايهاب عباس المحلل
السياسي ومن دبي تشوتشيوان الصحفي في
مجموعه الصين للاعلام شكرا لكما